what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with moonight cuz I know you
guys love the moonnight comics they are
so good and as always if you need to get
caught up there will be a link to the
moonnight playlist at the end of this
video that you can click on but what
this does is it picks up in miradon
prison and madon prison was basically
kind of like the new version of the raft
which is a prison system that's designed
to hold like superpowered beings it was
actually established during the events
of Devil's Reign but what you have here
is the Steve Grant Persona of Mark
Spectre having a conversation with the
Zodiac and zodiac is a villain that's
actually been around for a while in
Marvel Comics it feels like only
recently he's actually become like a
major foe of moonight he was there
during like the first or second Arc but
he's always kind of just been lingering
in the background ever since but the
funny thing about this is that you have
this conversation between Steve and
zodiac where in a lot of ways zodiac
just kind of taunts with him right you
know he was just like well obviously
you're not Mark Spectre and the response
to Steve is no I mean I'm not Mark
Spectre if I were Mark Spectre you'd
already be dead you'd be dead before you
ever sat down and what he does is he
just kind of like establishes control
like dominance over the situation as
soon as zodiac tries to exert his level
of control right it's kind of Steve
Grant just being like no no no no no do
not be confused I'm the one that holds
all the cards here right like I'm Steve
Grant I'm the billionaire right I'm the
billionaire personality of Mark Spectre
I've got all kinds of money I don't
really like getting my hands dirty right
prefer to do things elegantly and
honestly I prefer to have somebody else
do things for me right so here's the
question that you really have to ask
yourself while you're here in this
prison system how many people here do
you think want to kill you and how much
do you think I could pay them to do it
right I could give him $10,000 $5,000 I
mean I bet Dead Zone would do it for
like a th000 bucks right it would cost
me virtually nothing and so he asks him
are you the black Spectre and that's
when zodiac just starts laughing at him
right and it's one of these really
really cool things right he kind of says
and he makes a great Point here he was
like how long have we been fighting and
they really haven't been fighting all
that long at all but it's one of those
where he's like every time I committed a
crime to taunt you I would literally
write my name zodiac in Blood and Dot it
with a heart right you are my target
you're the guy that I want why in the
world would I take people out in an
effort to get your attention and then
not sign my name to it right like no I
am not the black Spectre right like I am
not that guy but it's really interesting
because he says like at the end of the
day right he's like you can tell your
black Spectre something from zodiac he's
like he better hope you find him before
I do because the reality here is zodiac
is hunting for the black Spectre right
not necessarily because of the fact that
they've got some kind of Vendetta at
least not as far as we know there's
probably some backstory there that
hasn't necessarily been explained in
some way it's just professional
jealousy it's really all it is right it
would be like if some villain showed up
in Gotham City and Batman decided to
chase that villain instead of Chasing
The Joker The Joker would kill that
villain so Batman would go back to
focusing on him and so what you do here
is you switch over to moonnight as he's
at the Midnight Mission and of course
the Midnight Mission is basically his
office people will show up there they'll
say hey moonnight I need your help with
something and if he deems it worthy and
if he believes that they're people worth
helping then he'll go out there and help
them but what ends up happening here is
he's actually meeting with a guy named
eightball now Jeff is ogou OG in Marvel
Comics this guy's been around since
forever and what he does really like
what eightball does is he says like
here's the thing I never went to black
Spectre right because right off the bat
you can tell they're basically talking
about the character of black Spectre and
the response of eightball is I didn't go
to him for anything he came to me now
that's one of the things to know about
how black Spectre operates often times
he will show up to somebody somebody in
a very strategic position or somebody
who has something that he needs and he
will say look I can give you what it is
that you need but you need to do
something for me in return right it
could be this person needs money or it
could be that they need a better job or
it could be they want to have somebody
killed whatever the case happens to be
right black Spectre will do it but he'll
ask for something in return and so what
ended up happening with Abal is he shows
up here and he was like look I couldn't
do it man right like he said I could be
part of the killing of moonight and
initially it appeared to me right like
being able to be one of the people that
took out March Spectre that's cool
because here's the thing to know right
like moonnight fans hate it when you say
this he's basically Marvel's Batman
right in almost every sense of the word
so killing moonnight would be like some
criminals in DC Comics killing Batman
you immediately make a name for yourself
and eightball would be a guy that people
would take seriously because unlike a
lot of superheroes in Marvel Comics
Captain America Spider-Man Thor
depending on whether or not he's pissed
off moonight has no quals with taking
people out if you piss off Mark Spectre
that guy will come find you kill you and
be home in time for corn flakes so to
make a name for yourself by killing that
guy it's going to draw a lot of eyes now
it might draw some EnV eyes but they
would second guess coming after you
because how dangerous are you that you
were able to kill moonight so the
response of of Mark here is take me to
black Spectre right take me to this guy
and so what you end up doing is picking
up in what's called heart Island right
the only real description we get is home
to New York City's 1.5 million nameless
dead right it seems more like a homeless
Community than any anything else but you
get this kind of back and forth between
the two now the relationship in the
history between eightball and Mark
Spectre kind of goes back a little bit
in the sense that while Jeff has been
around for a very long time there was
one point where he became a confidant a
broker of information for moonight which
is not uncommon right that's one of the
ways that he functions right you got the
three personalities you got Mark Spectre
the mercenary you've got Steve Grant the
billionaire and then you've got Jake
lley the cab driver the guy that keeps
his ear to the ground and basically
reaches out to people for sources of
information eightball was one of those
guys and so while you have them kind of
talking back and forth a little bit you
have like eightball asking Mark like
what happened to the Moon copter like I
mean what where did it go and he's just
like I mean I'm broke now man like I
don't really have much money to do
anything like that with I I couldn't
keep my pilot if you need a pilot I can
I can be a pilot and the response of
moonnight is kind of funny here he was
like you know how to Pilot a helicopter
and like eight Ball's like are you
kidding I'm a jet propulsion engineer he
says I designed and built a Hovercraft
in the shape of a ball rack and then
flew it around even which is true right
in the early days in the old Sleepwalker
Comics back in the early 90s like he did
man like he would just like fly around
on a giant eightball and attack people
at the time it was ridiculously dumb in
hindsight it was kind of cool to be
honest with you guys like it was kind of
dope right but at the end of the day
it's just because of the fact him
becoming a criminal is based on the fact
that when he was let go of his job for
his pool and gambling addiction there
wouldn't really a whole lot of
entry-level jobs out there for a guy
like him so he just ended up turning to
Crime instead and you get this really
interesting bit of camaraderie here
because he says sometimes it's just
easier to be the guy everyone thinks you
are you know and the response of
moonight is I do know because everybody
thinks I'm just the crazed guy with
disassociative identity disorder that
I'm like the most dangerous person and
the Avengers want to lock me up and they
keep me on a short leash and all that
kind of stuff and sometimes it's just
easier to be that guy more so than that
right and this was like the amazing
moment uh I think it was like in volume
one when you had that crazy guy who was
messing with people's heads and so
moonight just kind of allowed himself to
just become the just the crazy super
violent guy he ended up bringing that
dude into his own mind and he's like
this is what my mind looks like on the
inside come and worship and like drove
the guy insane and put him in a
catatonic State Like It's just sometimes
moonight just lets himself go which is
exactly what he's about to do because
what happens is that his him and
eightball get to their destination black
Spectre comes on the intercom and you
find out the whole thing was a setup the
whole thing was a trap it was literally
eightball showing up to get moonight to
come to where black Spectre was and then
he just bails on him he just takes off
and so from there you have black Spectre
that just kind of taunts moonight right
he just literally tells them these kind
of wild things right he says you do know
what it's like don't you moonight is
that why you came alone or worse than
alone with a traitor of course again
that's when eightball takes off and he
says but then you've always been a
cowboy haven't you and one of the cool
things about this is that while we don't
know a ton about black Spectre there's
seemingly history between him and
moonight right there's history between
these two guys which is a really cool
mystery that I'm excited to see unravel
but before anything can be done with
black Spectre the guy quote unquote
signs off and instead you get Rampage
replacing him now Rampage is a villain
who is interesting kind of right Stuart
Clark I mean he's okay he's very similar
to jigsaw and in fact it's very easy to
confuse the two which I think I may have
done when we were covering moonight
earlier but this guy is a genius when it
comes to technology and he sends all
these drones in right to start attacking
moonight now this is when you get to
like this really really cool and amazing
moment because what Stuart does is he
starts talking about the nature of
Technology he says that's what it's all
about you're obsolete sure you're Hell
on Wheels when you get your hands on
someone but I put a couple hundred grand
of hard ware in the field and you just
become a Target all that exercise all
that training years of work and you
can't even stand up to Consumer grade
electronics and so then he asked him the
question this this this is the reason
why I love Jed mccay's moonnight right
because it's just it's so amazing right
so he's like why the moonar rangs right
why throw these moons why don't you just
use a gun and so what happens is Mark
Spectre ends up destroying one of the
drones while he's being taunted right
and the response of Rampage is like you
think you're better than the rest of of
us with your sticks and your blades you
think that gives you the moral High
ground and the response of Mark is
hardly that's not the case at all it's
no big mystery Clark I don't like Who I
Am with a gun in my hand neither will
you and it's just like the most
moonnight thing to say dude it's just
like CU I got to be honest man I wish it
was lines like that that we got in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we didn't it's
just like I'm moonnight I kind of say
some cool stuff whatever but like you
see him for a total of what like I think
40 minutes over the course of the whole
length of the show so like they titled
the show after a character that you
rarely see hey guys welcome to Wolverine
the TV series where most of it focuses
on Jubilee like it's just it doesn't
make any sense at all and so what you
have is literally Mark just like taking
his time and going after Rampage he
starts taking out every single one of
these drones to the point where Rampage
is blind and so you get this really
funny thing where moonight was hit like
a couple of times and then black Spectre
chimes in and says that's enough of Mr
Clark for tonight I think and so
seemingly he took the guy out or at
least removed him right you don't
necessarily know with black Spectre he's
very clandestine with what he says and
so saying like that's enough of Mr Clark
could simply mean that black Spectre
just like walked up behind him yanked
him out of the chair threw him to the
ground and said go get out of here you
know go back home or go you know fix me
lunch or something like that or it could
mean that like he just put one in his
Dome piece there's no way to know right
there's no definitive way to know and so
what you end up doing is you have black
Spectre who kind of chimes in and he
says you left Rampage broken and
bleeding like you leave everyone in your
Wake the Dead cannot ask for Revenge but
the living must be offered a chance at
it so it's most likely that sewer Clark
is dead again we don't necessarily know
and he says and he's not the only one
you remember manslaughter marsdale I
trust he's very difficult to forget now
I forgot about manslaughter Mar marsdale
this guy man this dude he's he's OG
double OG I love manslaughter marsdale
like there was a point moonight took his
eyes bro he took his eyes so here's the
thing right like marsdale standing over
this guy right he was like where's your
tough talk now Moon Man the respon to
Mark Spectre son you better come strong
kicked him in the face right one-on-one
you're done son then you end up getting
like man Mountain Marco right like
moonlight's like you want something too
son like he gives it to him too's he's
like I got plenty to go around man I'm
in the business of what ass and business
is good right it's just it's one of
those things man like he just absolutely
trashes these guys and that's what's so
funny is because not one of these guys
really stand a chance against him and as
he's doing it he's just like talking the
greatest level of trash that I think
anybody's ever talked right like H like
like literally you have marsdale who's
like you're faster than I thought right
but I was a boxer man and the response
of Markus me too but now I'm a ghost and
so what you get is this moment man it
gets it gets ruthless right like while
marsdale is dealing with moonight you
have man Mountain who's just like
keeping busy dude I got something for
his ass dude revs up a chainsaw son
right so like as these guys are fighting
with each other what does moonight say
he was like okay so man slaughter you
can't feel pain that's cool but the pain
doesn't matter it's not important the
pain can't kill you not like a Cutthroat
moonight pulls out a mooning and just
like slices the dude throat wide open
man meanwhile you have like man Mountain
who just comes running up behind him
with a chainsaw like moonight catches it
with his hands and then like turns it
back on the guy and just like slashes
through his shoulder right and so it's
just like it's nuts because he tells
them he was like marsdale might live
maybe you will too but back in the
miradon I made you a promise Marco and
then from there cessa sights on getting
back to black Spectre now this is where
things get really cool because you have
this amazing monologue
by black Spectre right just like this
amazing monologue and I love the way
that it's written right he was just like
the dead and the dying you leave that
trail behind you you drag those ghosts
behind you which makes you so
fascinating to watch I am a student of
atrocity Mark Spectre an atrocity
follows you like a faithful Hound I had
my creatures engineer pesco's death
special no mere bullet or gero so I
could see what happened when I killed
him in front of you I killed your Shadow
cabinet to bring you here to watch you
to watch you die I can't let you live no
matter how interesting you are not once
you picked up my trail through sarac
after you stumbled upon Commodore Planet
but I have one more surprise for you one
more guest for our dance maob tell me
you remember I went to Great expense an
effort to secure this guest and you have
like these kind of just like bombs
detonators around this door and moon
Knight's like oh God right the bombs
detonate and after this thing comes
Waxman now for those of you guys who
don't know about Waxman Waxman is
arguably one of the most dangerous
villains in the entirety of the Marvel
universe that nobody ever bothered to do
anything interesting with this man is a
veritable oneman Army he's basically
Moon night's version of Clayface right
but like imagine someone like Clayface
taking on The Avengers outside of
somebody like Thor being able to channel
electricity which she may not
immediately realize like Waxman can copy
the appearance of other people and in
fact he used to do that in the early
days in the early days in the comics he
would take on the appearance of really
attractive guys and then like go find
girls and then like when he was about to
you know like like do the thing you know
just like wow like he would just lose
his form and he would end up like
suffocating these chicks he ended up
getting into a fight with spider girl
Jessica Drew and then she left him for
dead but the fact remains here like this
guy is incred incredibly dangerous but
what's so funny is you don't really get
to see a whole lot of him almost
immediately he kills moonight and that's
the coolest thing here right within two
panels moonight is about to die right
this guy's literally about to die and
then you have eightball that comes back
to the rescue and saves Mark Spectre by
just like shocking this dude all over
the place right because at the end of
the day and this is this is what's so
cool and I feel like you guys are going
to love eightball now I feel like you
guys are going to be like I want I want
to I want to see him more in the
moonnight comics I do I want to see
eightball more in the moonight comics I
love him because he rescues him and like
black Spectre is losing his mind right
he's like you're a dead man for this
eightball right you're dead you know
just like that's he's just screaming at
this guy but the whole rationale for why
eight ball save moonight is he says I
didn't want to be the guy everyone
thought I was anymore I wanted to be
somebody different and so what you do
here is you switch over to an epilogue
and what you get here is that at the
very beginning of the story there was a
guy with red hair who was basically
really met up with black Spectre and
black Spectre was going to Aid him but
he was going to ask for something in
return we didn't necessarily know what
it was right but it's this guy named
burrow and so burrow shows up to work
effectively late but when we get in
there we find out what his task was
right this guy puts a USB drive in the
computer system for the entire security
which I don't even know if you could
actually do this truth to tell but like
it takes down all the anti- air defenses
then it loads the PA system sarac MP3
and what it does here is it just drives
everybody absolutely insane there's just
like this massive riot that breaks out
while that's going on this helicopter
lands on the roof of a prison these guys
come out they spray everybody down
zodiac ends up making his escape from
this place and he realizes black Spectre
is the one that's basically behind all
of this but what ends up going on here
is that black Spectre meets with the
Zodiac you know and he was like speak
the devil's name and he shall appear
this is not black Spectre killing zodiac
this is a prison break he's literally
getting this guy out so they can all go
kill moonnight together with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end let me know how excited you are
to see the rest of this make sure you
click this link to the playlist to get
caught up if you need to and I will
catch you all later peace